Transcription: Amina Batsola
Relecteur: eric vautier
Désolée, j’aime bien me faire
désirer un petit peu.
J’étais coincée dans le rideau.
Bonsoir.
Merci de me recevoir ce soir.
Je m’appelle Lucie Carrasco, c’est écrit,
et j’ai choisi de ne communiquer
que l’âge de mon esprit.
J’ai donc 24 ans
et on ne rigole pas.
Je suis très heureuse
de parler avec vous ce soir
de la magie du temps
et de comment
j’ai décidé de ne plus subir le temps
et de ne plus en perdre surtout.
Le premier événement notable
de ma vie lié au temps,
c’est ma naissance
où les médecins ont lancé à mes parents
que je ne dépasserais pas
l’âge de trois ans.
Grosse ambiance
et c’est court comme temps.
Pourtant,
à 20 ans,
j’étais pressée de tout.
J’étais pressée de vivre,
pressée de réussir.
Je ne voulais plus perdre de temps,
j’estimais que j’avais déjà suffisamment
perdu de temps auparavant
et je ne voulais plus m’offrir ce luxe.
Je suis désolée.
C’est pas mal d’émotion, mais c’est cool.
(Rires)
Ça avait commencé ce rapport au temps,
et ce constat de perte du temps,
et en tout cas d’avoir l’impression
de gâcher mon temps et de le perdre,
avec ma maman.
Quand je suis née,
elle était absente.
Enfin, elle était sur la table
d’accouchement.
Elle était absente et elle a été absente
durant toute mon enfance,
et j’ai perdu beaucoup trop de temps
à essayer de savoir
pourquoi elle n’était pas là,
à l’attendre,
à essayer de comprendre pourquoi.
Et même si j’étais
une enfant hyper curieuse et souriante,
j’ai perdu beaucoup trop de temps
à attendre
de comprendre pourquoi
et surtout comment je pouvais faire
qu’elle soit là.
Après, vers 17 ans,
il y a eu l’école et mon orientation.
Et j’ai choisi de ne pas poursuivre
de grandes études
et de ne pas rester
dans la branche classique
parce que j’estimais encore une fois
que j’avais perdu assez de temps.
Effectivement, avant l’école,
il y a eu l’hôpital.
Et l’hôpital, ça a duré 5 ans,
d’affilée.
Cinq ans -
Oui, cinq années
à être quasiment tout le temps
allongée, enfermée,
à porter un corset de plâtre,
des attelles aux jambes avec des poids,
une minerve,
à essayer de m’installer tant bien que mal
pour pouvoir dessiner,
parce que j’adorais ça.
Un peu comme Frida Kahlo faisait avec
son corset et son miroir au-dessus.
C’est là que mon père
m’a parlé de cet artiste incroyable
et que je me suis dit :
« Je suis dans une chambre d’hôpital
mais au moins, il y a un peu
de style dans l’histoire. »
Il y avait Frida.
C’était aussi mon père
qui dormait dans sa voiture
parce qu’il y avait un seul hôpital,
où on pouvait me soigner.
A l’époque, il était à des centaines
de km de chez nous.
Il n’avait pas de sous pour se loger,
alors il a fini dans sa voiture.
Il fallait me soigner.
Il fallait me reconstruire.
Parce qu’être devant vous ce soir,
droite ou presque,
ça n’a pas été facile.
Ça n’a pas été tout rose.
Il a fallu m’opérer, il a fallu
que j’aie très peur
et que j’aie très mal
mais pour vivre.
Donc finalement, ça valait la peine.
Mais quand on repart à l’école,
j’ai 17 ans.
Depuis mes 12 ans, je suis à l’hôpital.
Et là, il est juste hors de question
que je perde une seconde de plus.
Même si c’était pour me sauver la vie,
je ne veux plus perdre de temps.
Du coup, je décide de m’orienter
dans la mode parce que c’est ma passion
et que je veux devenir créatrice.
Mais là, toutes les écoles de mode
me refusent.
Je ne répondais pas
aux critères de sélection,
comme on me l’a gentiment fait comprendre.
En fait, me revoilà à perdre du temps
à attendre qu’on veuille bien
croire en moi
et à chercher un établissement
qui voudrait bien m’accueillir,
nous accueillir,
mes grandes ambitions et moi-même.
Et après avoir franchi une tonne d’étapes,
je suis devenue créatrice de mode.
C’était cool.
J’ai fait quelques trucs sympas,
j’ai fait quelques défilés,
quelques collections.
C’est vraiment génial en fait,
parce que j’avais réalisé mon rêve.
Mais assez vite,
ma passion a commencé à s’essouffler.
C’était dû au fait que je n’arrivais pas
à trouver ma place dans mon pays
parce qu’on voulait absolument
que je véhicule une image avec moi,
une image visuelle.
Et en gros, ok, je pouvais créer,
être créatrice de mode,
mais je devais faire de la mode
pour les gens qui me ressemblent.
Et le communautarisme
ne m’a jamais inspirée.
Et là, qu’est-ce que je fais ?
Bah, je perds du temps
(Rires)
à essayer de prouver que j’existe,
que je peux faire des choses
et prouver qui je suis.
Et tant et si bien
que je fais un burn-out.
Je prends l’avion et me barre
à l’autre bout du monde
m’installer en Californie, à Los Angeles.
Oui, tant qu’à faire.
(Rires)
C’est là que j’ai commencé à vivre
et à décider de mon temps.
Pourquoi je vous parle du temps ?
Pourquoi il est aussi important ?
Parce que le temps
nous appartient, déjà.
Le temps nous appartient.
Le temps c’est la seule « sose » -
La seule « sose » ?
(Rires)
J’espère qu’ils vont faire
un petit montage quand même. (Rires)
Le temps nous appartient
et c’est la seule chose
qu’on possède vraiment.
Quand on arrive sur Terre, on est nu,
vulnérable,
et on a une chose : du temps.
Le temps de faire quelque chose
ou pas de notre vie.
Même l’amour inconditionnel
de nos parents peut avoir des failles
et n’est pas forcément acquis
pour tout le monde.
Mais le temps, lui, il est à nous.
J’ai eu des crises, en fait,
quand j’ai commencé à partir de chez moi,
à mettre la mode de côté
et les voyages en avant
parce que j’avais l’impression de mettre
mon temps à tellement bon escient.
J’ai commencé à jouer avec le temps,
à rencontrer un instant suspendu,
un moment suspendu.
Je me souviens, je suis à Istanbul.
Je me balade dans les rues.
Il est genre 17h30, le soleil couchant.
D’un seul coup,
c’est l’heure de la prière.
Du coup, les haut-parleurs
se mettent en route dans la rue.
Il y a ce chant et cette voix
magnifique venue de nulle part
qui se met à chanter l’appel de la prière.
Pendant que les gens
sont en train de prier,
les autres continuent leur business
dans la frénésie de la ville.
Et certains comme moi choisissent
de ne pas s’arrêter aux détails,
de juste se laisser transporter
par juste cette lumière de soleil couchant
et cette voix.
Je ne saurais vous dire si ce moment
a duré dix secondes ou dix minutes.
C’était un moment...
un moment suspendu
et c’était tellement beau.
Le temps n’est pas toujours le même.
Des fois il est trop court,
des fois il est trop long,
selon ce qu’on vit,
et des fois, il est juste suspendu.
Hors du temps.
Et ça, je le vivais
quand j’étais à Los Angeles
et que je choisissais de prendre le temps
d’aller voir un coucher de soleil
mais de le voir vraiment,
pas d’y aller et de faire la belle photo,
de le voir descendre jusque
derrière la montagne et même après,
quand on ne voit plus le soleil,
et qu’il y a juste
cette couche orangée du ciel
jusqu’à ce que la nuit tombe vraiment,
de choisir de prendre le temps de parler
avec cette femme assise à côté de moi,
sur un muret, que je ne connais pas.
On échange deux ou trois mots sur la vie.
Et je ne la reverrai
peut-être sûrement jamais.
Mais on a juste partagé un moment de vie.
Et sans doute qu’à l’âge de 20 ans,
ça m’aurait paru être une perte de temps.
Je me souviens du moment le plus notable
par rapport à mon changement
de perception du temps
entre mes 20 et mes 40 ans.
Donc maintenant, vous connaissez mon âge.
Oups !
(Rires)
J’avais essayé, bon,
ça a tenu quelques minutes.
En parlant de minutes, ça ne s’affiche
plus du tout sur l’ordinateur.
Merci. C’est un petit peu déstabilisant.
Du coup, ce -
Du coup, j’ai perdu le fil forcément.
Le moment le plus notable donc
de mon changement de perception du temps,
ça s’est passé au Japon.
J’étais à Hiroshima en tournage.
C’était mon nouveau métier -
ça, c’est une autre affaire.
On était devant le dôme de Genbaku
qui est le dernier vestige du bombardement
de la ville d’Hiroshima en 1945.
Un moment plein d’émotions,
de sentiments mélangés.
D’un seul coup, je vois cet homme.
Ce vieil homme assis sur un banc
en train de nourrir les moineaux.
Les moineaux viennent carrément
à même la peau sur sa main
pour se nourrir.
Ils sont environ cinq, dix, quinze,
peut-être vingt.
Je ne saurais même pas dire,
mais c’est tellement poétique,
et ça m’interpelle tellement.
Et là, je fais un calcul vite fait
dans ma tête.
Je calcule qu’il devrait
à peu près avoir l’âge
d’avoir vu ou vécu ce bombardement.
D’un seul coup, je décide de lui parler.
C’est devenu une nécessité absolue.
Mais je ne parle pas japonais.
Donc, j’appelle mon traducteur
qui s’enfilait des bières au bar.
Véridique.
Et l’air super vénère, je lui dis :
« Viens, viens vite, viens vite ! »
Je ne voulais pas que le monsieur parte.
J’étais prête à rester
le temps qu’il fallait
parce qu’il fallait absolument
que j’échange avec lui.
Et c'est ce qu'on a fait.
Effectivement,
il avait vécu le bombardement
parce qu’il habitait juste
à quelques pâtés de maisons du dôme
avec sa famille - et il avait 6 ou 7 ans.
Seuls lui et sa sœur avaient survécu
aux bombardements.
Les adultes, en tout cas les plus grands,
les grands frères, les grandes sœurs,
à ce moment-là, ont donné les oiseaux
à manger aux enfants et aux survivants
parce qu’il n’y avait plus de riz,
il n’y avait plus rien à manger.
Il n’y avait plus rien du tout.
Il n’y avait que des gravats
et des corps blessés,
quand ils étaient encore vivants,
et ils ont dû manger les oiseaux
le temps que tout rentre dans l’ordre.
Cet homme avait choisi de demander pardon,
mais surtout de remercier,
de remercier la vie
et de remercier les oiseaux.
C’est pour ça qu’il les nourrissait
tous les jours,
à cet endroit précis,
de les remercier de lui avoir sauvé
la vie quand il était si petit.
Et je me dis : « Mais...
Moi, vous, nous, n’importe qui aurait eu
une haine incroyable
de l’horreur qu’il avait vécue,
haïr la guerre, haïr l’ennemi,
les Américains,
le connard qui a appuyé
sur le bouton et balancé la bombe.
Et au lieu de ça,
ça a été pour lui l’opportunité
de passer une vie,
un moment sur Terre bien meilleur
que s’il avait été rongé par la haine
et de passer un temps
et une vie de gratitude.
C’était la plus grande
crainte de ma vie en fait.
Il m’avait calmée
et j’ai pleuré d’émotion,
d’admiration.
Je pense à lui tous les jours parce qu’il
est une source d’inspiration au quotidien.
C’est cet homme qui a terminé
de me convaincre
non seulement que la vie,
c’est maintenant,
mais que le temps n’est
que ce que l’on en fait.
Il avait compris à quel point
le temps et la vie étaient précieux.
Oui, c’était beaucoup d’émotion
et c’était très émouvant.
Alors oui, à 20 ans, je voulais vivre vite
et à 40 ans, je veux vivre bien
et savourer.
Grâce au temps, on peut avancer,
évoluer, changer d’avis, se tromper,
se casser la gueule.
Mais, on peut rester
fondamentalement qui on est,
tout en ayant une vision du temps
complètement différente.
On passe, en fait, de subir le temps
à savourer le temps.
Et ça n'a plus rien à voir.
Les échecs, les embûches,
ne sont pas forcément là
pour nous anéantir.
Ils sont là surtout
pour nous offrir des opportunités.
L’opportunité de s’arrêter,
de réfléchir, de changer de voie,
de découvrir qui on est vraiment.
J’aime voir les embûches
comme des opportunités.
En ce moment, c’est dur, on galère.
Mais finalement quand on cherche
une opportunité cachée,
c’est un peu moins dur.
Alors, on pourrait penser -
On pourrait penser
que c’est le discours d’une femme
qui a juste envie de ne rien faire -
« Maintenant, je savoure ».
Pas du tout, pas du tout.
Je suis débordante d’ambitions,
bouillonnante de projets
et j’ai envie de travailler,
et ce n’est absolument pas incompatible.
C’est juste de placer le curseur
à un autre endroit
et de réaliser que la vie
n’est que ce que tu en fais
et que tu es la seule personne
à pouvoir décider
de ce que tu vas faire de ta vie.
Peu importe ce que tu en feras,
tant que c’est toi qui la choisit,
personne ne pourra rien dire
parce que c’est ton temps à toi.
Vivre et saisir les opportunités.
Je viens d’y penser,
j’ai oublié de vous dire une chose.
Je suis handicapée.
Je suis vraiment désolée
pour ceux qui, en se basant sur la photo,
étaient venus écouter
pendant un quart d’heure
parler de handicap et de fatalité.
Cependant, pendant toutes ces minutes,
je n’ai pas prononcé
une seule fois le mot « handicap ».
Et pour autant,
il était présent, omniprésent,
parce qu’il était là, tout le long
de ma vie que je viens de vous raconter.
Il a participé en quelque sorte
à me faire devenir la femme
que je suis aujourd’hui.
Et ça prouve juste une chose,
c’est qu’il n’y a pas besoin de nommer
le mot « handicap » pour qu’il soit là.
Je pense que le handicap
c’est plus un détail qu’un problème.
Ma maladie, mon handicap,
en fait, c’est la meilleure
chose qui me soit arrivée.
C'est la meilleure opportunité de ma vie.
L’opportunité
de comprendre ce qu’est le temps
et à quel point il est précieux.
Oui, ça paraît étrange de voir
quelqu’un de malade,
ou de très malade, selon votre curseur,
en train de dire que c’est
la meilleure chose qui lui soit arrivée
mais je suis reconnaissante, encore plus
depuis que j’ai rencontré ce monsieur,
reconnaissante à la vie
de m’avoir apporté tout ça.
Comme vous l’avez vu,
mes médecins se sont trompés.
J’ai eu plus que 3 ans
et j’aurai même plus de 40 ans.
Les médecins avaient estimé mon temps,
mal estimé, mais ils l’avaient estimé.
Mais c’était sans compter que c’est moi
qui déciderais de ce que j’en ferais.
Merci beaucoup de m’avoir écoutée.
(Applaudissements)